[Music]
gentlemen you can come in and have a
seat
[Music]
I like to keep students waiting in order
to let the tension
build
so do you know why you're
here no
no well I've graded your papers on
hume's dialogues and I noticed a
problem there's a paragraph in both
papers that was copied directly from
Wikipedia ring a bell uh what's
Wikipedia I don't even know what
Wikipedia
is guys lying is just going to annoy me
now this isn't the end of the world the
policy here at dwu is that you'll be
reprimanded for cheating you'll be given
an F for the class but if you don't have
any future incidents your record will be
cleared at
graduation however if you get caught
again it's expulsion so stop lying and
stop cheating cheating that's a strong
accusation proof do you have I'll give
you this warning one time don't act like
I'm a you copied an entire
paragraph from a Wikipedia
article or did we just happen to write
the exact same thing that's on this
Wikipedia without copying it yeah ever
heard of coincidence coincidence
coincidence coincidence
son what are the odds that two students
in the same class working on the same
paper would end up writing not only the
same paragraph As each other but the
same paragraph I found on
Wikipedia entirely by
coincidence why are you asking us you're
the one calling people cheaters tell us
what the odds are well I'm not sure how
to calculate an exact probability but
let's just say one in 100 million
trillion
so you're telling me there's a chance
let's go with that one in 100 million
trillion so are you saying that if
something's got a probability of one in
100 million trillion it can't
happen it wouldn't be logically
impossible but it would be
unbelievable one in 100 million trillion
would be 1 in 10 to the 20th that's
these odds now you say that's something
beaten these odds would be unbelievable
but when the universe is forming the
gravitational constant was so precise
that if it had been even slightly
different by one part in 10 to the 60th
power we wouldn't exist right now and
the gravitational constant is a joke
compared to the fine-tuning of some of
the other constants so obviously if
these odds can be overcome by chance
there's no reason we couldn't have
written the same thing you found on this
Wikipedia well the standard response to
the fine tuning argument is that if
these constants didn't have the values
that they have we wouldn't be here to
notice them so the fact that we're here
assumes that the odds were
overcome yeah and if we didn't write the
same thing as whoever wrote the
Wikipedia article totally by chance you
wouldn't have noticed the similarities
so the fact that you're in here accusing
us of plagiarism assumes that this is
all a coincidence quinky dink
H I guess you have a point if universe
is the product of chance I just have no
basis for accusing you of
plagiarism thank you
gentlemen I'm afraid I owe you an
apology not only do I withdraw my
accusation I hereby declare that no
matter how similar your future papers
are to Wikipedia articles I can never
accuse you of cheating because the odds
of you writing the exact same words that
a Wikipedia author came up with no
matter how many times it happens are far
better than the odds of the universe
being able to support life by chance if
I can believe that the Universe formed
without a designer I can believe
absolutely
anything apology accepted
[Music]
thanks atheism
but